PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Are you migrating
your monolithic application
to microservices on GKE?
Then I bet that data is a
huge part of that migration.
Stay tuned to find out
more in today's episode
of Get Cooking in Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: When it
comes time to migrate data,
the strategy you use
depends on the answers
to a few important questions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, how much
data do you need to migrate?
CARTER MORGAN: How often
does this data change?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Can
you afford the downtime
represented by the
cut-over window
while migrating that data?
CARTER MORGAN: What is your
current data consistency model?
There's really no single best
approach to migrating data.
Today, we will share four
different data migration
approaches, each of which
tackles different issues
depending on the scale and
the requirements of the data
migration.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: The
data migration approach
you use is based on the
cut-over window size
that your application
can tolerate,
the refactoring effort
that your team can handle,
and the amount of flexibility
each approach offers.
CARTER MORGAN: The
scheduled maintenance period
is ideal if your workloads
can afford a cut-over window.
It's scheduled in the sense
that you can plan when
the cut-over window occurs.
Here's how it looks.
Copy data from legacy
sites to new site
in order to minimize
the cut-over window.
For more details, refer
to the earlier episode
on migrating in stages.
Compare the legacy data
against the new data
set to make sure there
weren't any copy errors.
Stop further data from
being read into the system
during the migration.
Synchronize any changes that
happen after the initial copy.
Deploy new versions of
the workloads and services
that use a new site.
Start the workloads
and services.
Retire the legacy site
when you no longer need it
as a fallback option.
This approach places most of the
burden on the operations side,
because minimal refactoring
of the workload and system
is needed.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Not all workloads
can afford a long
cut-over window,
so the continuous
replication approach
builds on the scheduled
maintenance approach
by providing a
continuous replication
mechanism after the initial
copy and validation steps.
Here's what that
would look like.
Copy data from legacy
site to the new site
in order to minimize
the cut-over window,
just like we did in the
scheduled maintenance approach.
Then, we compare the legacy
data against the new data
to make sure there
weren't any copy errors.
Set up a continuous replication
mechanism from the legacy site
to the new site.
Stop further data from
being written to the system
during the migration.
Refactor workloads and
services to use the new site
and wait for the replication to
fully synchronize the new site
with the legacy site.
Then, start the
workloads and services.
Retire the legacy site
when you no longer need it
as a fallback option.
This approach is more complex
than the scheduled maintenance
approach, but it
minimizes the time
for the required cut-over
window by minimizing
the amount of data you
need to synchronize.
CARTER MORGAN: If your
workloads have hard,
high availability requirements
and you can't afford a cut-over
window, a different approach--
what we're calling the Y
recipe--
would make sense.
In this recipe, the workload
is writing or reading
data in both the legacy
site and the new site
during the migration.
Here's how it looks.
Refactor subsystems
to write data
both to the legacy
and the new site
while reading from
the legacy site.
Copy data into the
new system that
was written before the new
site began to write data.
Compare the legacy data
against the new data
set to make sure there
weren't any errors.
Switch read operations from the
legacy site to the new site.
Perform another round of data
validation and consistency
to check data.
Disable writing in
the legacy site,
and retire the legacy site
when you no longer need it
as a fallback option.
Unlike the scheduled maintenance
and continuous replication
approaches, the Y writing
and reading recipe
shifts most of the effort
from the operations side
to the development side due
to the multiple refactorings,
but it does not require
a cut-over window,
which is a plus.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now, if you want
to reduce the large amount
of refactoring effort needed
in the Y approach,
you can centralize
the data read and
write operations
by refactoring the workloads
and services to use data access
microservice.
This scalable microservice
becomes the only entry point
to your data storage
there, and it
acts as a proxy for that layer.
It's actually pretty
similar to the Y approach
we discussed earlier.
The only difference is
instead of refactoring
the entire service, we
focus the refactoring effort
on the data access
microservice alone.
Refactor the data
access microservice
to write data both in the
legacy site and the new site.
Reads are performed
against the legacy site.
Identify the data
that was written
before you enabled the
writes in the new site
and copy it from the legacy
site to the new site.
Along with the
refactoring above,
this ensures that the
data stores are aligned.
Perform data validation
and consistency checks,
comparing data in
the legacy site
against data in the new site.
Refactor the data
access microservice
to read from the new site.
Perform another round of data
validation and consistency
checks comparing data
in the legacy site
against data in the new site.
Refactor the data access
microservice to write only
in the legacy site.
When you no longer
need the legacy site
as the fallback option
anymore, retire it.
In a microservice
architecture, this recipe
is the preferred
method and gives you
the maximum flexibility, because
you can refactor this data
access component
without impacting
other components
of the architecture
and without requiring
a cut-over window.
It does put a burden
on the developer side,
but it's significantly less than
the Y approach we discussed.
CARTER MORGAN: So in summary,
we looked at four recipes
to migrate data, although
picking the right option
would depend on
weighing the pros
and cons for your situation.
For more information about
migrating a monolith to GKE
and these data
migration strategies,
refer to the article linked in
the description below written
by our friends, [? Marco ?]
[? and ?] [? Teo. ?]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, there you have it.
If you are looking to migrate
a monolithic application
to microservices,
then today, you've
got a taste of different
data migration recipes.
CARTER MORGAN: And don't
forget to check out
the collab in the link
below to experience
an end-to-end migration
of an e-commerce website.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's all for today
on Get Cooking in Cloud.
Let us know how you're liking
the series in the Comments
section, and hit those Like
and Subscribe buttons for more
cool Google Cloud content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]